with my career for the first time
players are going to be able to create
their own superstar and sort of live
that dream and to see you know where we
really did push the envelope it's
exciting you know and then once we got
here to 2k you know of course you know
mbit my fav years of experience working
on career mode so you know they're
everybody working together we were able
to to really dial in what that
experience would be for us you know in
terms of wrestling actually this whole
mode is because of the fans you want to
deliver a game that's something they
could play for a really really long time
we definitely want to try to give
players that experience of beginning
from the very bottom and taking the
character growing your carrot evolving
them we could not do a career mode
without nxc that is everybody's first
stop you're gonna get into rivalries
with all the top guys are you fighting
for positions on pay-per-view and work
your way up to Wrestlemania and
SummerSlam it's rags-to-riches almost
you know you are you're lucky hopeful
down there in the Performance Center in
Orlando Florida and you take them from
the bottom I wait to the top
I
don't let go of that foot when you turn
him over don't let go of this okay you
know I mean if I rely on you if I'm
gonna do this and say hopefully he knows
how to take a good bump but if I don't
throw it I open the door for him to do
with what he wants so it's his
interpretation if you take him he knows
exactly where you want to go the
performance center has changed
everything this place here in Orlando is
going to transform sports entertainment
industry and of course it's the home of
NXT similar to the manatee baseball
system to where you have different
talents come and you grow and you see
the double a triple a single day and
they move up and then one day they get
the call to the major leagues and NXT is
really where you have to become good to
get into the ring here and then become
successful at the NXT level to make it
to the next step which is raw and
smackdown
I'm not sure how many people in like
Nathan you go to go to a training center
for a few weeks and all of a sudden you
become a WWE Superstar and so much goes
into in so much hard work and desire and
passion and a lot of broken hearts to be
able to see that process be an
eye-opening experience it's really great
for me but it's great for the fans to
know that we have one house one place
and we house the greatest entertainers
in in our industry that will be coming
up so when I first got to a performance
center it was amazing you'll seeing them
trained for for the first time and
seeing them learn the ropes of what it
means to be a WWE Superstar that was
exciting there's nothing in the world
like it probably the mecca in terms of
sports entertainment facilities we have
seven rings we have a state-of-the-art
weightlifting facility with training
room so we are in here as much as we
possibly can working honing our craft
and hopefully soon making our way up to
SmackDown Monday Night Raw once you get
to that main roster it's all about
making a name for yourself you're gonna
have choices into which way you want to
go do what do I want to go for the
United States Championship well via fan
favorite or a rule breaker all these
things sort of factor into you know how
your career is going to play out to see
that come to life in the game is what's
going to be the intriguing part you're
building someone's career you're growing
with them you're going to go through it
with them and we're going to take you
there oh here we go we knew these two
wouldn't be able to get through this
without beating each other senseless and
now the ability to be able to bring a
lot of these Superstars and divas from
NXT the life is really really exciting
part of the game and it's going to give
people a tremendous opportunity to
really vary the amount of superstars and
divas that they're able to play in this
game to be part of this game is huge for
these kids this is groundbreaking and
now to be recognized as part of this
project is just it's just amazing
everyone at this trial at some level of
training or experience but we don't care
about your resume here if you look at XD
it's the
giant roster of superstars who are on
the brink of becoming that next big
thing it really is a very organic way of
going about experiencing what it must be
like to be a true-blue WB superstar
we're gonna have a few surprises out
there we're definitely have some dlc
we're gonna have more NXT superstars
added into the mix blossom to have new
move sets if you're going to be able to
download which is gonna be pretty cool
and also we're just gonna listen to the
fan so for each year we can make a
better and better game it's just a game
that I feel is gonna be like no other
it's gonna be an experience that they
never had in the past this is gonna be
the best I think fans are gonna love it
I'm ready for this game are you ready
for me in this game